[Applaus] wir singen jetzt ein Lied
if your happy and you know it Clap Your Hands
if you happy and you know it and you really
want to showing [Musik] ihr seid gut drauf
ja mir geht's gerade nicht so gut in meinem Leben
geht gerade alles bergab in ich folg damit einer
Familientradition in meinem Familienstammbaum
befinde ich mich auf einem absteigenden Ast
mein Urgroßvater war noch Professor Doktor mein
Großvater war Doktor meine
Mutter hat zu Ende studiert
ich kann aufrecht laufen
ich bin von Beruf dem Motivationstrainer und als
demotivationstrainer habe ich natürlich eigene
Ziele meine Ziele sind immer beruflich will ich
scheitern privat möchte ich erfolgreich sein
jetzt ist es umgekehrt ja das traurig ja ich
hoffe euch gefällt mein Beitrag sonst haben wir
hier gleich eine klassische loose loose Situation
ist wirklich alles schief gelaufen ne
obwohl ich immer letzter werden will
bei kabarettpreisen bekomme ich einen Preis
nach dem anderen das ist Mobbing [Applaus]
es ist bei mir in den letzten drei Jahren so gut
gelaufen dass ich theoretisch
drei Jahre Pause machen könnte
okay wenn ich mich nur von Zwieback ernähren
würde und die Miete nicht zahlen würde aber
ich hatte mir immer vorgenommen ins Fernsehen zu
gehen um extra besonders schlechte
Leistungen abzuliefern das blöde ist
mit schlechten Leistungen fällt man
im Fernsehen gar nicht mehr auf ist
ich habe mich gefragt was man überhaupt
tun muss um zu scheitern scheitern kann
ja nur wer etwas will so gesehen laufen
die meisten gar nicht Gefahr zu scheitern
apropos scheitern es folgt jetzt noch ein
Beitrag unter meinem Lebensmotto no fun no fun
aber wieder nichts besseres zu tun fahre mit einem
Regionalzug von Siegen nach Köln habe irgendwie
den Verdacht dass dieser Tag eine Niederlage
wird versteht ihr Siegen Köln Niederlage
in dem Kampf aussteigt eine Grundschulklasse
ein ich hasse Klassengesellschaft
kommt bin ich um Single von kleinen Menschen tun
reflexartig hole ich meinen iPod raus ist das Ihr
iPod meine Schwester hat einen größeren iPod die
Viertklässlerin gegenüber hat mich gerade gedisst
wie heißen sie ich bin Nico ihr könnt mich duzen
der Junge mit dem Pinguin Rucksack stellt fest
du hast Löcher in deinem Pullover warum hast
du ein kaputten Pullover das ist mein Stil
was machst du vom Beruf ich sage
dass ich auf Bühnen vor Publikum
auftrete und Witze erzähle erzähl
mal einen Witz was liegt am Strand
und ist schwer zu verstehen ein
Mann mit Sprachstörung [Musik]
hä du bist nicht witzig
was machst du da ich schreibe auch wie er mich
beleidigt daraus kann ich bestimmt lustigen
Text machen willst du den Text jetzt auf die
Metaebene heben meterwitze sind doch kacke
die Stelle verstehe ich auch nicht
ein anderes Mädchen zeigt auf meine Brille
du bist bestimmt was blind nein willst du mal
meine Brille aufsetzen ich reiche sie ihr ohne
Brille siehst du scheiße aus setzen wieder auf
jetzt bin ich verletzt ich hole mein Handy aus
der Tasche um meinen Therapeuten anzurufen warum
hast du so ein hässliches Handy hast du
eine Freundin jetzt fange ich an zu weinen
Kinder nächste Station müssen wir aussteigen
alle stehen auf und warten in einer Schlange aufs
aussteigen ein Mädel ruft mir hinterher benutzt
du Clearasil ich kann dir das sehr empfehlen
dann ist die Klasse weg und
ich bin wieder allein allein
[Applaus]
ach so abonnieren Sie diesen Kanal
dann wird's lustig ihr Puffer